[Music]
for anyone in any creative Pursuit
making something with an audience in
mind to me is always sort of like the
death now you know like make something
that you want to make like what is the
story you want to tell and that's what
you put out into the world because when
you start to be
I think product oriented over process
oriented
yeah it can get you into some trouble I
think you just have to keep going and I
think making your own work is really
important like Daryl and I made work in
the face of 1000 Knows by just going and
doing it ourselves how to grow as an
artist is to is to do things that you
don't know how to do right and to not be
uh so afraid of the thing that scares
you that it paralyzes you from exploring
it